December 15 Joe Biden apparently were
being told the records for John FK
assassination uh are going to be
released and the reason why they said it
wasn't released uh because we were
supposed to get it earlier was
significant impact that a covid-19
pandemic if you guys remember that
October 23 2021 but hopefully by
December 15 2022 it'll be released and
Trump was also one that hesitated a
little bit to releasing the docs it
seems to be a trend I mean it's been 59
years and they're still not releasing it
uh what What's your speculation on why
this thing keeps getting uh backed up I
I think your audience probably needs a
little background on what the review
board was and why we're in this
situation today when JFK came out back
in 1991 it created a firestorm of
controversy and because at the end of
his film Oliver Stone wrote that the
files of the house Select Committee are
classified until the year 2029 which was
the last investigation and they closed
in 1979 so the question was why do we
have to wait
50 years to learn the last things about
John F Kennedy's assassination so
Congress created this what we call
assassinations record review board which
had unprecedented powers in the history
of of record declassification
well they did not finish their work they
only had a four-year Lifetime and so
what happened is
this dragged on and dragged on and
dragged on the terminal date where
everything was supposed to be let go was
2017. so that comes up and Trump says
about a week before I'm really looking
forward he Tweets in I'm really looking
forward to releasing these last files on
the JFK assassination and so what
happens he doesn't right he didn't why
are they afraid of releasing it this is
what was in the most of the papers is
that he got a last minute visit by the
FBI right and the CIA and what what
these guys do and because I I know this
for a fact is that they come in and they
and they read the riot act to the and by
the way let me add this the only person
who could have stopped a
declassification was the president
because it says that right in the law
and so they they usually give you this
speech about if you if you let these go
you're gonna end danger the life of a
lifelong agent or some kind of ongoing
operation now how the same agent could
be in place 50 years later is really
amazing to me so he
what he did is he asked for a six-month
extension
then when the six-month extension was up
he asked for a three-year extension
which actually went beyond his
presidency and so this then bounced to
Biden all right and Biden uh released I
think about 1400 pages
and he said we have to wait because Nara
is somehow behind the curve due to the
coveted uh epidemic you know what what
they were doing in the intervening 20
years I don't know okay and so now now
the new terminal date is about three or
four weeks from now December the 15th
and I can tell you for a fact
that Biden was already planning to delay
that because I know some of the lawyers
you're aware that got a lot of publicity
that they filed a lawsuit against Biden
and Nara in Northern California to force
the declassification Well in that
lawsuit they have that information that
he was already planning on another delay
but what's the do you know the reasoning
behind it I mean it's it's got one he
was on the review board so why why are
you guys delaying it as you know maybe
we ought to blame you what is wrong with
you
why do you think they're delaying it if
you were to give your perspective before
we get into what we really think
happened so so I'm you know I I this is
a very personal thing for me after all
the work that we put in
uh to actually find people you know uh
find records or arrange Deeds of gift
transfer of Records to the National
Archives and Records Administration all
the visits to archives one and two and
other facilities around the country to
do research
just like Jim said you know I kept
looking on the JFK collection it's on
the National Archives records
Administration website to see my record
group
and here's the interesting thing
uh you can find records of mine in other
people's records groups but not in mine
which doesn't make sense right so I I'm
just as upset about this because in my
mind we were doing that work to
literally provide a centralized place
and and let the American people decide
you know don't hold a thing back I mean
yes I was taught to do you know Skip
tracing find people things like that we
didn't have Google
um that that's a skill you have to be
taught to do that there are sources and
methods associated with how I was able
to do that I don't think those things
should be released however it like you
said it doesn't take 20 years to to just
take those things and what threat and
you have to really have an actual threat
against the country and against
Nationals so so you know you know uh uh
you watch movies like argue about what
is that sound that clicking noise you
hear it
what is that clicking noise it's like
somebody's clicking something do you
hear that okay so you know can I can I
want to say something hang tight so so
I'm from Iran okay and I watched the
movie Argo and you watch the movie Argo
with Ben Affleck and you see what's
going on in Iran with the whole movie
Canada everything that they did they
waited 30 years like how come you don't
release this earlier well you gotta wait
30 year CIA whatever the numbers are
right
and then you look at this this is 59
years okay it's similar to when they
said you know the the covet
investigation cannot take place till
2076 or whatever the number that they
put that's like 50 years from now 40
years from now right 50 years from now
and they're like Why Can't This Be not
investigated for 50 years is it because
the people who are making those
decisions are not going to be around 50
because so then it goes back to the
point of 1963 today 59 years most of
those guys have been dead that were part
of it anyways only a few people of that
right so who who's protecting who at
this point is it Legacy what's being
protected see one of the things that
John tuneheim talked about when we
interviewed him and his the rest of his
interviews in the book all right he said
these guys really they don't want to
give up anything all right and he said
he described the first meeting with the
CIA
and he said he threw up a document on
the screen
and he said what on Earth could you
possibly object to right and
declassifying that document because the
cam there was nothing in it that seemed
to endanger anything all right and so
the CIA guy looked at the document for
about a minute or so
and they're waiting and waiting and he
says give me a couple of minutes I'll
think of something see that's the kind
of attitude these guys have that's been
inbredded into their well-being so what
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks right if you believe future
looks bright get your latest Future
looks bright hat of valutamin it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]